頑張っても信頼されないというはてな
はい このテーマについて考えてみましょう
みんな認めてくれない
評価されない 感謝しない
感謝されないでしょうね
などの文句を言ってますでしょうに
私も嫌になるほど聞いているんです
その文句は 相手の反応を管理できないんですよね
認めなさい 「はい 認めます」と言ったっても気持ち悪いでしょうに 「
はい 感謝しなさいよ」と 「
はい 感謝します ありがとうございます」と
いや意味がないでしょうに
だから我々は あの 世界はそれほど管理できないということは理解しましょう
周りが理性人ばかりでできているわけでもないんです
みんなエゴイストで わがままで
煩悩の に 汚れて 汚れて
煩悩に 何と言いますか
この お-溺れてもう死にそうになっている人間様でしょうに
で 人のことを感謝する余裕がないんで
自分の煩悩で溺れてもう死にかけているんです
だから この これは成り立たないんですね
他人の認めを期待する人より
他人の認めを気にしないで責任を果たす人こそが優れています
ですから 優れた人は他人が感謝するかしないか気にもしない
病院の仕事をする看護婦さんとお医者さんと同じく責任を果たす
医者さん お医者さんが
ちゃ では「なんであんた感謝しないのか」と聞いて
一度も聞いてくれないよ
期待もしてないんです
自分の責任を果たす だからあの人々に結構パワーがあるんです
看護婦さんでもね 何か言っちゃうと「嫌です」と言えなくなっちゃうんです
言う通りにするんです
なぜならば その方々は責任を果たしてます
それはまあ職業の問題で
人は病気になるともう危険だから
命に関わる問題だから
そちらはもうすごい責任感を持って自分の仕事をしているんです
我々もそれと同じく 社会がうまくいかないと社会全体的に滅びますから
一人一人の責任をすごい責任感で果たさなくちゃいけないんです
それは優れた人格者になる方法なんです
人格者と優れていると
それだけで信頼されるんですよ
人格者は信頼されます
それは自分でこの修行で得なくちゃいけない能力なんですね
はい 次に行きます まあ時間もかなり飛びましたからね
はい それだけですよ それからこの信頼関係の四つの基準
一人が責任を果たす人が
なおさら四つの項目がありまして
これもシガラ経典にありますよ
で この四つの項目を守った方が
あえてブッダのアドバイスなんですね
好かれる人間になります
信頼される人間になります
一 ダーナ ダーナっていうのはもうみんな布施施しと書いてますけど
やっぱり助けること 与えることですね
だからいつでも自分の能力
何か何か他人に与えるもの
与えられるものは全て与える
アドバイスをしてあげる
知らないことを教えてあげる
困っている人は助けてあげる
悩んでる人にはなんとかちょっと慰めてあげる
とにかく施しをやるんです
施しの場合は感謝してくれと言っちゃうと施しになってないんです
自分の性格として施しをするんです
ペイヤワッチャっていうのは
言葉を喋る場合は いつでも聞く人に聞きたくなるような優しい言葉を考えて喋らなくちゃあかんですね
特に あの 命令形は嫌がるんですね
で あの 敬語かどうかはそうあまり関係ないんで
時々敬語ではなくて すごく
あの 乱暴な言葉でも相手が喜んじゃう場合もありますよ
だからこの それはそのケースバイケースで
まあ鬼と言われた方が喜んで舞い上がってくる子供たちもいますからね
で 人に鬼というのは決して敬語じゃないんだけど
やっぱりこのケースバイケースでではなく
心が傷つく言葉を 絶対に避ける
それで自分の能力が上がっちゃうし
人間関係はものすごくうまくいくんですね
次にアッタジャリヤっていうのは
役に立つような生き方をする
いつだって自分が人に役に立つ
喋るときでも役に立つことを喋る
行為も役に立つようにすると
これで人は助かりますと
公園を掃除でも同じ役に立ちますでしょ
番目 一番大事サマーナッタタ
これは同値と訳しますが
サマーナッタ みんな同じだよと
みんな生命だよと ある人が私に聞いた質問があって
なんでそんなにもあなたに動物が寄ってくるのかと
私は私は動物は動物と思ってないんだよと
同じ私と同じ生命やと思ってるんだから
対等で喋ったり喧嘩したりしていますよと
あの対等の気持ちは結構もう受かりますよと
受かるというんですか
結構受けますよと だから動物は可愛い可愛いと言っちゃうと
なんか自分が上で可愛がられて
動物の立場がなんか下になっちゃうんですね
動物でもやっぱり対等好きなんですよ
動物の飼育係のね だからチンパンジーとか猿とか面倒見る人々の場合でも
猿は相手と同じだと思ってるんです
猿は猿扱いする チンパンジーチンパンジー扱いすると
それで関係がややこしくなるんです
だから飼育係の人々は本当に上手な人々はやっぱりなんか対等で見ているんですね
だからすごくプロになってるんですね
だからこのサマーナッタタ
全ての生命は同等であると見ること
このつ守れば もうものすごい素晴らしい人間になるんです
だからお釈迦様がありがたいのは
そうやってこの数字で短くまとめてくれてるんでしょうね
このつは この社会関係
どうやってより良い素晴らしい社会関係を築くのかといったら
このつ守りなさい それで終わり
お釈迦様はこれは世は車に例えて
昔の車ですね だから軸に車輪が入れてるんですね
だから車輪が外れないように軸に釘を刺してるんですね
釘を外してしまうと車動いちゃうと車輪が両側で落ちちゃって車が壊れるんです
だからこの車輪を止めてる軸のようなものであると
という風に私は訳しますけど
あるいは 車輪の中にある塾だと訳する場合もあります
そういうことですごい大事なポイント四つなんです
次に行きます それで お釈迦様がシガラ経典でこう結論するんで
エーテーサンガハナスナマタプッタカーナラべたまなんプージャンワピタワプッタカーナ
この四つの条件がなければ
母は我が子からも信頼尊敬を受けることはない
父も我が子からも我が子からさえ信頼尊敬を受けることはないんだ
ですから 両親と子供の関係であっても
この四つを守るべきなんです
子供は自分の部下じゃないんです
対等で見なくちゃ 子供にも愛語を使わなくちゃあかんです
怒って怒鳴ってはいけないんです
信頼される秘密として
この四つの条件を実行しましょう
はい 次 うっかりミスを避けるというポイントに行きます
間違いは起こすもの それでも結果が悪く
人間は間違いはしますよ
誰も完全な人はいませんからね
だからって間違い起こしたら困りますよ
それを理解しましょう
誰だって間違いは起こすもの
しかし 間違いによって悪い結果が当然出てくるんです
その中でも判断間違いは
避けるべきです 人間の行動は判断から始まるんです
まず判断して行動する
だから我々は判断間違いだけしないならば
この体で言葉でちょこちょこっと間違いあっても
あ ごめんって そうすみません
判断間違いは気をつけましょう
感情で心が濁ると濁ると判断は主観的に間違えます
だから感情で心が汚れないように
濁らないようにしなくちゃあかんです
感情が出ると感情が優先になると
判断決して正しくないんです
怒りがこみ上げてくると
欲がこみ上げてくると
嫉妬が優先になってくると
どんな判断でも間違いなんです
はい それで我々は感情と言ったら煩悩は千五百ありますからね
全て管理できないでしょう
それでお釈迦様が四つにまとめているんです
四つだけ守ればいいんです
なぜならば お釈迦様が完全に語ったんです
完璧に語ったんです 煩悩は千五百あるんです
で 自分が気をつける場合は四つにしているんです
チャンダドーサバヤモーハ
ヨーダンマンナティワッタティ
アプーラティヤソタッサスカパクヘワチャンディマ
一チャンダ 自分の好みで判断してはいけない
判断するときは好みは基準にしない
店でご飯選ぶときはいいんだけど
それでも好みで判断すると病気になるでしょう
例えば糖尿病の人々っていうのは
遺伝子でなければ甘いもの好きなんですよ
だから食べるもの選ぶときでも
好みで判断避けた方が身の安全なんです
二番目 怒り 機嫌が悪いときは機嫌が悪いんだから判断することだけ避ける
三番目 映え ちょっと怖い
あ この人ちょっと怖いんだから
じゃあ言う通りにしようとかね
それはやめてください
怖さは判断に使わない
四 無知ですね 無知ですね
もう訳もわからない もう全然わからない
だからどうでもいいやと言うと判断する
それやめてください 訳もわからないんだったら
自分で判断しないで訳分かる人に聞いたらどうですかね
まあ頭がごちゃごちゃになって訳も分からなくなって
とにかくやりますというのはやめてください
だから四つ守ればうっかりミスは避けられるんです
この四つに限られる限り陥らない人の信頼は
これ一単語あると思いますけど
出てこなかったんですね
月が大きくなる十五日
何て言いますかね  白分の月とか言いますけどね
あんまり使わないですね
あんまり使わないね だから新月は月がいませんね
それからどんどん十五日間かけて
毎日毎日月が大きくなって大きくなって真ん丸くなっちゃうんですね
そのように自分の信頼性が増えますよと
優しさっていうのは信頼性ですよ
みんな褒めることなんです
いい人やと だから十つ守ればいいでしょうに
その人は判断ミスは起こさないんです
はい 次にブッダの真理の教えに入ります
信頼することも信頼されることも超えるというね
存在欲渇愛があるから信頼されることは大事なんですよ
しかし それで依存する関係が成り立って自由が失いますね
だから人間は自由がなりません
人間 なぜならば人間に存在欲があるんだから依存しなくちゃいかんですね
他の生命に 心の感情 煩悩をなくすと
他の生命に依存することも徐々になくなります
だから我々一人一人 自分の感情をできるだけ減らしてみるんです
感情を減らせば減らすほど
依存することがなくなるんです
たとえ自分に子供がいても
感情がなくなっていくと
ここで依存することはなくなる
自由になるんです 自由になったら
ものの見事に人の管理もできます
心が清らかな人は完全に信頼できる人です
それで煩悩なくなったら
存在欲 渇愛が消えたら
その人は超越した唯一信頼できる人なんです
完全に信頼できる人っていうのはブッダと阿羅漢たちなんです
でも誰も信頼してくれないんです
面白いことに しかし その人は他人に依存しないで生きるので自由です
お釈迦様には仏教徒がなければ困るということは一切ないんです
しかし 信頼できるんです
はっきりお釈迦様は言うんですね
仏法僧というのは 理性のある人には何の疑いもなく信頼できる道だよと
だから 何のことなく信頼してみなさいよと
あなた方は確実に幸福になりますよと
だからもうこれもう派手に言わなきゃ理解しないこと
ぐらいなんです ずっと歴史見ると
ブッダに逆らうことしか人間考えてないんです
はい そういうことで 信頼される人間になるよりは
仏教いうのは信頼するされるということは超えたら完全たる信頼できる人格者になっているということです
はい 次 はい それ あの あの講演が終わりましたので
あの 後書きにします 人間関係のマップ
これシガラ経典のマップなんですね
マータピターディサプッバアーチャリアダッキナディサプッタダーラディサパッチャミッターマッチャッチャウッタラーターダサカッマカーラカラヘッターウッダンガ
サマナブラームナエターディサナマッセイヤアラマットウクーレギヒ
で あの インド文化的にはこの方向で第一は東なんです
太陽が東から現れるんだからね
ですから 東は一にしています
東は両親です 自分の命が両親から現れたんだからね
だから東は両親 両親に
えっと六つの責任ありまして
それは果たしてくださいと経典にあります
東から右回りに行っちゃうと
次 南 東から右に回ると南があるんです
南は師匠 というのは自分に物事を教えてくれている人々
そこでも義務があるんです
先生の話を真面目に聞く
宿題をやる 先生のお世話をするとか
いろんなものがあるんです
さらに右に回ると西 西は妻子
子供にはいないんだけど
大人には妻子がいるんだから
そちらにやるべき仕事
責任 義務があるんです
自分の責任 義務を果たすんです
果たしたら お釈迦様が言うのはオートで他人も自分の責任
義務を果たすんだよと
さらに右に回ると北 北は友人ですね
ここで友人という場合は仕事の仲間も入ります
私には友達はいません
ただ仕事をしているんだったら
そちらの人々いるんだからね
そういうみんな友人として見なくちゃいけない
だからその友達にどういう風に対応すればいいかとお釈迦様が経典に書いてありますから
勉強してみてください
で そこをやりたくなければ自分たちで考えて
まあ完璧に考えられないかもしれませんだけど
友達にやるべきことをやってあげたら
友達はもうやるべきことをやってくれるでしょう
くれなくてもどうでもいいんです
例えば 会社の仲間に対して自分の責任を果たせば
向こうは責任を果たしても果たさなくてもどうでもいいんです
自分の位置が安定しています
それで下 下は まぁ 雇っている人々
今の現代社会ではね それほどみんなサラリーマンたちだから
まあ雇われている人々ばっかりなんですけど
まあそれでも雇っている人々がいる場合は
その人々に対する責任先に自分が果たすんです
それで上 現代人に上もないんですね
上っていうのは もう仏教ではシャマンバラモンといって
この宗教形なんですね
まあインド文化では人には宗教あるということは当たり前のことで
宗教といっても信仰する宗教よりはお釈迦様いうのはこの善悪を教えてくれる人々
だからそれはこの修行者たちがよく分かっているんです
だから精神指導者たちというふうに私は現代訳したんですね
この四つを まあ六つを我々の人間マップなんですね
ブッダの時代でお釈迦様に説かれた人間マップなんですね
それは東西南北上下ということになるんです
はい そこで 現代人にはこの六方もなければ
現代人も自分の人間関係マップを考えた方がいいんですね
責任果たすよりは この人間マップを
人間関係マップを作ってください
自分に関係ある人々は
こういう こういう こういう人々やとマップを作って
これで東西南北に入れておいて
で 東西南北でこの優先順位も分かりますね
だけ 東は一番優先で 二番目は南なんですね
それから結婚したら西の方になってくるんですね
はい で 我々はどうすればいいかわからないんだから
この人間関係のマップを作ったら
やるべきことは明確に出てくるんです
文句言われないようにマップに合わせて責任を果たします
社会から文句言われないように
自分のマップを見ながらレイアウトを見ながら責任を果たします
信頼される人間になる修行はそれで完成します
自分の人間マップを作ったら信頼される人間になります
はい 次に行きます で ラストポイント
最後のポイント ワンラストポイント
これだけでも十分です
Be truthful to others and to yourself
まあ一般英語で言えば No cheating なんです
自分にも他人にも嘘をつかないこと
信頼を獲得する最後の武器です
様々な条件 能力の問題などが割り込んで義務責任を果たせなくなることもありますよ
義務を果たさなくちゃいかんだけど
なんか条件があって割り込んできて果たせなくなる場合もあります
しかし 素直で真実のみを語る人の信頼性は決して失いません
だから 今まで長い講義を全部ワンポイントにまとめるとそれだけです
Be truthful
それで お釈迦様が気が遠くなるほどのものすごい過去から修行したという伝説あるんですよ
もうもうもうもう光年単位で数えているんですよ
菩薩として修行を積んだこと
この菩薩として王様にもなる
百姓としても生まれる
バラモン人の家も生まれる
えーと ポタっていうのは
あの 何といいますか この器を作る家にも生まれるし
それからカースト低い家にも生まれる
いろんな生まれ 生まれるんだけど
それで王様になったら悪いこともしなくちゃいかんでしょうに
しかし 菩薩になると決めた日から一つだけ道徳を一貫して守ったんだと
喧嘩することもあるし
いろいろあったんです
この一つだけ守った 一貫して守った道徳は嘘をつかないことです
ですから いかにそれが強い道徳かと
だから我々も No cheating という生き方をするならば信頼されるんです
はい これで話が終わるでしょうね
おそらく はい どうも ありがとうございます